dans son vieux par-dessus râpé il s'en
allait l'hiver été dans le petit matin
frileux
mon vieux
il y avait un dimanche par semaine les
autres jours c'était la graine qu'il
allait gagner comme on peut
mon vieux
l'été on allait voir la mer
tu vois c'était pas la misère
c'était pas non plus le paradis
[Musique]
dans son vieux par-dessus râpé il a pris
pendant des années le même autobus de
banlieue
mon vieux
le soir en rentrant du boulot il
s'asseyait sans dire un mot il était du
genre silencieux
mon vieux
les dimanches étaient monotor
on ne recevait jamais personne
[Musique]
ça nous rendait pas malheureux
je crois mon vieux
dans son vieux par-dessus râpé les jours
de paie quand ils rentraient on entend
des gueuler un peu
mon vieux
nous on connaissait la chanson tout y
passait bourgeois patrons la gauche la
droite même le bon Dieu avec mon vieux
chez nous il y avait pas la télé
c'est dehors que je l'ai cherché
pendant quelques heures l'évasion
[Musique]
c'est
con dire que j'ai passé des années à
côté de lui sans le regarder on a peine
ouvert les yeux
ou deux
[Musique]
j'aurais pu cette époque
avec lui un bout de chemin ça aurait été
rendu heureux
mon dieu
mais quand on a juste 15 ans
on n'a pas le cœur assez grand
pourri loger toutes ces choses là
[Musique]
maintenant qu'il est loin d'ici
en pensant à tout ça je me dis
j'aimerais bien qu'il soit près de moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut pas se faire ensemble juste le
premier couplet de du gitan avec plaisir
mon garçon j'adore c'est une de mes
chansons préférées tu as travaillé cette
nuit
j'adore il a un rire de voyou dans les
yeux ses amis incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on dit de musique s'en fout de
connaître
il aurait pu être un grand
retour là je te
[Musique]
prendre une guitare être musicien mais
sa vie à lui elle est dans ses bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la chanson je l'avais je l'avais écrit
pour un pote quai boxeur qui s'appelle
Pierre Franck Winterstein qui était
super boxeur pour moi
donc on l'a fait comme ça pour rigoler
et c'est devenu un tube j'adore merci
mon Daniel